you've written quite a punchy piece uh
in the sunday telegraph uh calling on
diado harding the head of test and trace
to be given a well-earned break
polite way of saying she should be
sacked why do you think it's time for
her to move on
she's achieved a huge amount and there's
a great deal of very good work going on
in
test and trace and that shouldn't be
undervalued and i
i do mean this as kindly as possible to
her she's
been a tremendous asset but uh
the test and trace capability clearly
needs to move up several gears
and it's what leadership does not who
leadership is that really matters
at the moment there are four separate
directorates
and it's impossible to plan effectively
across
all directorates because many of them in
separate places there is no single place
to do planning from and then the
delivery is overseen by
uh a diverse group of of the
directorates i mean
why is the the um cabinet office covid
um covid operation uh
announcing something today about the
numbers of days that may or may not be
re-quarantining for how does that fit
into an overall strategy
and it is the sense that there is a lack
of an overall strategy
which i think is is at the heart of the
problem
saying that there's a lack of an overall
strategy
you're clearly concerned about test and
trace itself but do you feel there's a
lack of strategy
more widely in the government's response
to covert 19.
well that's that's the second point i
make the first thing is that test and
trace should be
a campaign to persuade people to do the
right thing
uh people being telephoned and
instructed what to do often
four or five times being instructed to
do the same thing
again and again this is not winning
consent and compliance in fact it's
undermining the credibility of the
operation and then you find
some people aren't telephoned at all but
on the wider picture
i'm recommending that the government
should set up a high level strategic
group and this is where i think
you know someone like dido harding and
her experience would be so valuable
to think much longer term uh to use that
experience
about the lessons learned and work out
how we're going to
be living with this virus i mean we keep
hearing a vaccine may come at any minute
but it's most unlikely there will be a
single vaccine that gets us out of
all this problem and challenge in one go
it's
likely to be several vaccines or several
vaccinations
because this this disease is far more
like um
you know regular flu it can it's going
to adapt it's going to change it's going
to be with us for a long time
and we need to work out how to make sure
that we can open up our economy and live
our lives
alongside this virus we can't move from
lockdown to lockdown
so if the viruses can be with us as you
believe for potentially quite a long
time that a vaccine may not be the
silver blow that some people hope
what should the strategy be well we need
to
adapt our working practices and our
living practices
uh over a period of time to make sure
that
we can lead as normal lives as possible
um but recognizing that um
a a big rise in the virus infection rate
uh is a big risk there's a big story in
the sunday times this morning
about um how the patients were having to
be triaged on a very
crude basis we all knew this was going
to be inevitable if we were
swept swept along by a big outbreak of a
deadly virus
but uh not all the people can be treated
now the government's priority
one of their priorities is to make sure
that the hospitals are not overwhelmed
again
and that's a very important priority so
we've got to learn how to suppress the
steadfast spread of the virus
um we can't allow it to um
as some people call it let rip i don't
think anyone's really advocating that
but uh if if the virus infection rate
goes up too far
well then we will damage the economy one
of the depressing things about
the way that this is developed it's as
though and again it's um
referred to it by a government spokesman
that somehow the government's got to
navigate between two extremes either
controlling the virus
or supporting the economy actually these
two things have got to be aligned
they're the same thing if we don't
manage to control the virus effectively
it's going to have very serious
consequences for the economy
but at the same time we must make sure
the measures we're taking to control the
virus
are not deeply damaging to the economy
we want a fusion of these two
objectives uh not them to be sort of
intention and opposition to each other
it's a false choice
you've um questioned the strategy you've
you've also brought up the fact that
you worry that people just aren't
complying when told to self-isolate by
test and trace
do you think there's a risk that the
government is effectively losing people
oh definitely yes i think um the whole
row about free school meals is a
um a touchstone of how
little faith a lot of people now have in
the government's
uh conduct of this and the government
can get it back
but that's why i recommend that in fact
leadership of test and trace should be
handed over to
um a very senior military person
who is used to dealing in a crisis
situation
under stress at scale with very high
degrees of complexity
and organization that's what a senior
military
commander is trained to do and that
their
ability in that is unique now there are
lots of military people
involved in tests and trace but they're
not
involved in the overall leadership of it
and that's what that's the most
fundamental recommendation i'm making
just finally to pick up on something you
just said there about the free school
meals i mean it's worth pointing out you
did actually vote with the government on
free school meals didn't you
well that's a good guess in fact i was
absent for that vote but i would have
supported the government i
freely admit that but i think we have to
admit that uh
um we've misunderstood the mood of the
country here
um yes we've given money to local
government my own essex county council
he's got a program funded by central
government that's going to be supporting
kids who needs
pre-school meals across the county but i
think that
the public want to see the government
taking a national lead on this
and i think the government will probably
have to think again on that uh
particularly if there's going to be more
votes in the house of commons
i think when you've got the chairman of
the education select committee
um and not supporting the government on
this and he's a conservative
i think the government has to listen to
the conservative party and it's
understandable that the government wants
to get back the idea that there isn't a
bottomless pit of money and there's got
to be some financial discipline
but i think again they've got to manage
their situation
and balance balance the pressures and
the urgency that people feel on this
very quickly then so if it does come
back to the house of commons for a vote
how would you vote on preschool meals i
shall wait and see what the government
says
and how they respond to the situation